on the hill tonight for the giants will
be the left-handed veteran alex wood
alex wood
30 years of age and he's in his
eighth year at the big league level this
season off to a great start
3-0 and four stars from the 196 era with
22 strikeouts in 23 innings against five
walks isaiah kiner falefa chalet off
chases that back foot slider swing at a
miss strike three for three pitches and
a strikeout
to begin the game brings up nick solar
solak strikes out swinging through that
slider again and he got him two down
back-to-back strikeouts for alex wood
and up comes
the left-handed inning first baseman
nate lowe drive to left field talkman
moving over quickly to his right he'll
get there and make the catch on the move
four out number three alex wood nine
pitches in the first inning on the hill
tonight for the texas rangers will be
the veteran kyle gibson gibson 33 years
of age in his eighth year at the big
league level this is what he's done this
year he had a rough first start after
that he's been money 3-0 in the year
with a 2-4-0 here right mike talkman
leading it off that one
out to left field and a diving catch by
chris davis wow first chance we've seen
him have defensively as a ranger
and who said chris davis could only be a
dh that was a special defensive play
right there so talkman was robbed here's
ustremski and this one
lifted to short center field and garcia
takes care of it here is buster posey
another good day yesterday at the plate
for buster what a start to the year for
him and that one is off the plate
outside ball four fastball posey draws
another walk so here's brandon belt
chance to hit with a man on base belt
hits it high into the air deep left
center field garcia has room going back
to his right just a little shy of the
track he makes the one hand grab and
that'll do it for the giants giants
nothing ranges nothing as adolesce
garcia leads off for texas and longoria
picks it
one away so far four up four down for
alex wood as the left-handed hitting
joey gallo steps into the batter's box
brandon belt waves off wood
gets the unassisted put out gallo out
number two two outs for davis here's a
swing and a grounder to short crawford
has it he played back to get a truer hop
he knew he had time and he throws out
davis so alex wood very quickly retires
the side in order evan longoria lead off
the home second for san francisco
mongoria blasts one deep out to left
field davis is there
one away
here comes brandon crawford and that's
on the outside corner called third
strike and that's the first strikeout
for kyle gibbs two outs for wilmer
flores swinging a miss from a hard
slider away gibson sets him down in
order alex woods retired all seven that
he's faced so far and jonah heim will
come to the plate and this one blooped
over second could be trouble drops in
base hit haim will be the first base run
of the night for the rangers kyle gibson
now comes to the plate this one is
popped up on a bun and belt's going to
come in and catch it for out number two
two outs
runner at first for
kiner falefos ball right to short that's
where crawford was playing he'll throw
the short way to second floor is on the
bag for the force out well pitched on
both sides so far alex wood for the
giants kyle gibson for the rangers
strike three called and wood goes down
looking no complaints it's two down for
mike talkman strike three caught over
the inside corner and it's a one two
three inning for gibson and the rangers
now nate lowe to the plate his game he
goes to the opposite field with
regularity on the ground left side
another opposite field hit for nate he
slides in safely with a dribbling ground
ball double
that beats the shift yet again so it
brings up adonis garcia on the ground
but right to longoria
he freezes the runner a little low but
beld helped him out so two down and here
comes the slugger joey gallo ground ball
hit shot to the belt at first he's got
it on a tough hop and runs it to the
back for the put out joey gallows gone
on one pitch one hit low stranded at
second giants have not yet had a hit
against kyle gibson who has been on
quite a roll nine in a row retired by
gibson
here comes brandon belt with two down
and the base is empty now belt swings
and he drives one deep left center field
way back there still going still going
goodbye
a home run for brandon belt to the
opposite field
the giants get their first hit and their
first run all at the same time
one-nothing giants chris davis leading
it off with a rangers davis a career 286
hitter against the giants this is high
in the air out to right field back to
the wall
and that one is high off the fence and
he's in there with a triple that's a big
triple right after the rangers gave up
the first run of the game charlie the
one guy in the lineup today who's seen a
little bit of alex wood and has handled
him well over the years this ball hit
hard up the middle base hit and we are
tied at one charlie culverson with an
rbi single and we're tied at one
the rangers have just tied it up here at
one in the fifth but now on a
a hit off of
gibson's foot and a flukey hit into
shallow left here the giants have minted
first and second with nobody out for
steven duggar swinging a ball hit back
up the middle off the mound izzy's got
it steps on second for one throws to
first to complete the double play and
that's the ideal result for gibson and
the rangers it
who's been immaculate with his control
has walked the last two batters and has
done so on nine pitches so a chance here
for the rangers the big boppers coming
up garcia and galloway swinging him as
he struck him out
hard to throw it better than that in a
strikeout situation jobs not finished
joey gallo with his monstrous power got
him swinging and a big fist pump from
alex wood and after the two walks
he strikes out the next two hitters so
here's longoria first and third two down
the 0-1 pitch
swinging the ball the tit hard but kiner
falefa up with it he flips to solac so
you got heim now the switch hitter
batting right-handed wood's got it he's
going to throw a change up to second for
one flores though adjusted nicely has it
at second and throws to first for the
double play
so the giants cooking here in the bottom
of the seventh two on two outs mauricio
dubon the pinch hitter bond lines one to
left field davis is going to have to
play it on a bounce here comes slater
around third the throw coming home with
nothing on it slater scores
and into second on the throw mauricio
dubon who comes through
with one of his biggest hits in a giants
uniform two more in scoring position
here for ustremski and bounce toward
third leaning in to play it on a
backhand culvers in his throw to first
and it kicks away from low
ruff is in to score an extra run for the
giants three to one jake mcgee will try
to get the final three outs for the
giants and so now the tying runs are on
base for the rangers in the ninth inning
and the batter is the veteran
charlie culverson popped up
crawford
and longolia it's longoria and the ball
game is over